Die Geschichte beginnt
in der Schweiz, im Rheintal.
Und sie führt in die ganze Welt.
Es geht um Waffen,
um Kriege und Armeen.
Und einen Wissenschaftler
namens A. Q. Khan.
Ohne das A.-Q.-Khan-Netzwerk
wäre Pakistan heute keine Atommacht.
Es ist die Geschichte
über die Atombombe,..
..die gefährlichste Waffe der Welt.
A. Q. Khan ist einer der gefähr-
lichsten Kriminellen der Welt,..
..der viel tat für die Verbreitung
der Atombomben-Technologie.
Er wird von Pakistan bewundert,
respektiert und geliebt.
Dann wird A. Q. Khan verraten -
von einem Schweizer Mechaniker.
Sein Name ist Urs Tinner.
Er spricht erstmals öffentlich
über seine Erlebnisse.
Gestützt auf seine Informationen
hätten die westlichen Geheimdienste..
..auf einem Frachter
im Oktober 2003..
..verdeckt unter Containern
Atombomben-Teile gefunden, sagt er.
Das Khan-Netzwerk war entlarvt.
Ich riskiere im Prinzip
heute noch mein Leben.
Das ist heute noch die Frage.
Man weiss noch nicht,
was, wie endet.
Einer wie Urs Tinner
ist der Traum jedes Geheimdienstes.
Er liefert Informationen und arbei-
tet gleichzeitig im Netzwerk weiter.
Tinner spielte eine wichtige Rolle..
..bei der Nichtverbreitung
von Kernwaffen.
Das Rheintal: Diese Gegend,
besonders die Ortschaft Haag,..
..gefällt in den 70er-Jahren
einem pakistanischen Wissenschaftler.
Am Telefon: Spreche ich
mit Doktor Abdul Qadeer Khan?
Die Stimme gehört ihm: A. Q. Khan.
Khan ist ein berühmter Mann
in Pakistan.
Er gilt als Vater
der pakistanischen Atombombe.
Im Mai 1998 ist es so weit.
Pakistan zündet unterirdisch
seinen nuklearen Sprengsatz,..
..die sog. islamische Atombombe.
A. Q. Khan wird als Held gefeiert.
Pakistan hatte grosse Probleme
mit der Sicherheit.
A. Q. Khan löste diese
in einer unkonventionellen Weise,..
..indem er die Bombe baute.
Dafür reiste er
in der ganzen Welt herum.
Er offerierte seine Dienste damals
dem pakistanischen Präsidenten..
..und sammelte um sich
ein Team von Offizieren,..
..Wissenschaftlern und Ingenieuren.
Die Nation ist ihm deshalb
zu Dank verpflichtet.
Er ist ein grosser Nationalheld.
Am Telefon gibt Khan Auskunft zu
seiner Rheintal-Bindung, auf Deutsch.
Denn er studierte
vor vielen Jahren in Berlin.
Das Wohnhaus der Familie Tinner
im Rheintal:
Friedrich Tinner ist ein begabter
Ingenieur und Funk-Amateur.
Khan und er verstehen sich gut.
Friedrich Tinner kann seinem Freund
beim Atombomben-Bau helfen.
Khan ist deshalb oft hier zu Gast.
Zu dieser Zeit geht der kleine Urs
noch zur Schule.
An Khan könne er sich nicht erinnern.
Ich machte bis zur 6. Klasse
eine normale Schulausbildung.
Dann verbot mir der Lehrer, an
die Sekundarschulprüfung zu gehen.
Es ist eine Abschlussklasse
ohne Fremdsprache,..
..eine vereinfachte Schulbildung.
Der junge A. Q. Khan in Holland
anfangs der 70er-Jahre:
Er arbeitet als Wissenschaftler
in der Urenco,..
..einem Gemeinschaftsunternehmen
des Westens.
Hier wird Uran
für die Atomkraftwerke angereichert.
Ein streng geheimes Verfahren,..
..denn mit angereichertem Uran
kann man auch Atombomben bauen.
Er ging nicht als Spion dorthin.
Urenco brauchte ihn damals, als sie
diese Uranzentrifugen entwickelten.
Khan realisierte,..
..dass er auf einem Berg
von nützlichen Informationen sass.
Er spricht Urdu, Hindi,
perfekt Englisch,..
..aber auch Holländisch und Deutsch.
Er konnte
alle Dokumentationen lesen.
Er startete seine nukleare Karriere
in Pakistan,..
..indem er in einem Brief an den
damaligen Präsidenten Bhutto schrieb
Er schrieb ihm,..
..er könne Technologie und Wissen
über Urananreicherungen stehlen.
Er schrieb Bhutto sogar 2-mal.
Die 70er-Jahre: Der damalige
pakistanische Präsident Bhutto..
..besichtigt
einen importierten Atomreaktor.
Bhutto will die Atombombe. Doch
der Westen verweigert jede Hilfe.
Pakistan selbst scheint unfähig,
eine Bombe allein zu bauen.
Als Khan nach Pakistan zurückkehrte,
war das Land kaum in der Lage,..
..Nähnadeln zu produzieren.
Und trotzdem konnte er
eine funktionstüchtige,..
..effiziente,
nukleare Organisation aufbauen.
Und dann nutzte er
seine Kontakte quer durch Europa,..
..um Ausrüstungen für Pakistans
Urananreicherungsprogramm zu kaufen.
Als er nach Pakistan zurückkehrte,..
..nahm er nicht nur
die Urenco-Pläne mit,..
..sondern auch die Lieferliste,
die Namenliste derjenigen,..
..die Ausrüstung, Rohmaterial
und Technologie an Urenco liefern.
Der Name Tinner war auf der Urenco-
Lieferliste, die Khan mit sich nahm.
Tinner wurde Khan
durch Wissenschaftler empfohlen,..
..die Khan kennenlernten, als er
in Deutschland und Leuven studierte.
Und hier können Sie..
..diese grossartige, organisato-
rische Begabung von Khan erkennen.
Das sog. Vakuum-Valley
in der Schweiz,..
..diese Quelle von Technologie,
dorthin muss ich gehen.
Bundesarchiv Bern:
Hier lagern die Akten über Khans
erste Schweizer Kontakte -..
..vergessen und unter Verschluss.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen
fand die Dossiers..
..und erhielt
die Ausnahmebewilligung,..
..die vertraulichen und nie
publizierten Dokumente einzusehen.
Sogar die Visitenkarte
des damaligen VAT-Ingenieurs Tinner..
..ist hier abgelegt.
Tinner informierte offen über den
Exportantrag für eine Vakuumanlage.
Pakistan benötige, so Tinner,..
..die Ware für eine geplante
Urananreicherungsanlage.
Bern wusste also Bescheid..
..und erlaubte am 12.8.77
den Export trotzdem.
In einer offiziellen Biographie,
publiziert 1992,..
..dankt A. Q. Khan dafür der Schweiz.
So sei er zur wichtigsten Ausrüstung
gekommen.
Die Schweizer Regierung
ist also mitverantwortlich..
..für die nukleare Fähigkeit
Pakistans.
Washington protestiert
damals energisch,..
..droht der Schweiz sogar
mit Wirtschaftssanktionen.
Es wird hin- und hergeschrieben -
vertraulich, confidential.
Im Rheintal geschäftet Vater Tinner
weiter mit Khan.
Sohn Urs überlegt währenddessen,
was er werden könnte.
Ich wollte erst
eine Kochlehre machen.
Ich schnupperte als Bäcker/Konditor.
Das gefiel mir nicht,
weil ich früh aufstehen musste.
Dann suchte ich einen Mechanikerjob.
Bei Mechanik AG in Haag
fand ich eine Lehrstelle,..
..ein ganz normaler Mechanikerjob.
19.3.1979: Der US-Geheimdienst
macht die Schweiz..
..auf eine Rheintalreise
von A. Q. Khan aufmerksam.
Doch nichts passiert.
A. Q. Khan reist noch oft ins
Rheintal zu Vater Friedrich Tinner,..
..der inzwischen
die Firma VAT verlassen..
..und ein eigenes Unternehmen
gegründet hat.
Khan erzählt am Telefon:
Probleme gibt es erst im Jahr 2004.
A. Q. Khan
wird in Islamabad festgenommen.
Verraten vom Sohn seines
Geschäftspartners Friedrich Tinner,..
..von Urs Tinner,
der inzwischen zum Spion wurde.
Urs Tinner ist seit Ende 2008
auf freiem Fuss.
Über 4 Jahre verbrachte er
in Schweizer Untersuchungshaft -..
..zu Unrecht, wie er sagt.
Alles beginnt
mit Problemen in der Schweiz.
Nach der Scheidung gab es Probleme..
..wegen den Kindern
und dem Besuchsrecht.
Sie fehlten mir sehr.
Ich versuchte die Schulden,
die sich anhäuften, abzuzahlen.
Ich bekam immer wieder Probleme mit
der Gemeinde wegen den Steuern,..
..die noch offen waren.
Ich sagte mir, ich muss weg.
Ich weiss nicht mehr,
wie ich darauf kam,..
..aber irgendwie
kam dann Dubai in Frage.
Im November 1998
fliegt Urs Tinner nach Dubai.
Warum ausgerechnet Dubai?
Ein Vorschlag seines Vaters,..
..der wenige Monate vorher
Khan in Dubai traf?
Daran will Urs Tinner
sich nicht erinnern können.
Tatsache ist: Urs Tinner
trifft ebenfalls auf Khan.
Ich wusste nichts über ihn.
Er war ein älterer Mann,
sprach gebrochen Deutsch,..
..eigentlich gutes Hochdeutsch.
Er war darum der Einzige ...
Wie es so im Ausland ist:
Man versteht niemanden.
Und plötzlich kommt jemand,
der Deutsch spricht.
A. Q. Khan erinnert sich im
Telefoninterview auch an Urs Tinner:
Mir ist aufgefallen,
er war ein Mensch,..
..von dem ich eigentlich heute
sagen muss:
Ich kann die Vorwürfe
nicht nachvollziehen.
In seiner Wohnung sind viele Bilder
von Vögeln und Blumen.
Er ist sehr naturverbunden.
Es ist jene Zeit, in der die paki-
stanische Armee Finanzprobleme hat.
Die USA haben
ihre Unterstützung gekürzt.
U.a. weil sie mit
der nuklearen Aufrüstung Pakistans..
..nicht einverstanden sind.
Dia pakistanische Militär- und
Geheimdienst-Führung warnte die USA:
Wenn ihr uns nach dem Sowjet-Rückzug
aus Afghanistan die Mittel kürzt,..
..müssen wir andere Methoden finden.
Die Warnung war allgemeiner Natur.
Später wurden sie konkreter.
Wenn ihr uns
die Unterstützung streicht,..
..verkaufen wir
unsere Nukleartechnologie.
1991 begann Pakistan,
die Drohung wahr zu machen.
A. Q. Khan erhält den Auftrag.
Er beginnt, die Technologie anderen
islamischen Nationen anzubieten.
Khan drehte den Fluss um. Er wurde
vom Importeur zum Exporteur.
Er verkaufte Pakistans
Atomwaffen-Geheimnisse und Teile..
..des Urananreicherungsprogramms
an Iran, Nordkorea und Libyen.
Er offerierte es also dem Irak.
Er richtete
unermesslichen Schaden an,..
..indem er
Atomwaffen weiterverkaufte.
Es gibt keinen Zweifel:
Khan arbeitete für die Geschäfte
als Vertreter seiner Regierung.
Es gab auf der Welt
kein anderes Netzwerk,..
..das so gross und bedeutend war
wie das von A. Q. Khan.
Sie konnten das Wissen verbreiten,..
..wie man Urananreicherungs-
Zentrifugen baut und betreibt.
Aber zusätzlich
hatten sie auch Informationen..
..über den Bau von Atomwaffen.
Und dieses Material
war auch lieferbar..
..für die Kunden
dieses sog. Netzwerkes.
Dubai ist der Schauplatz
dieses Handels.
A. Q. Khan hat hier
eine Wohnung gemietet.
Und er hat hier eine Art
Geschäftsführer eingesetzt,..
..den Srilankesen BSA Tahir.
Tahir spielt eine Schlüsselrolle.
Ich lernte Herrn Tahir
in Dubai kennen.
Er sagte, er wolle
eine Firma aufbauen,..
..eine kleine Werkstatt,
um Teile herzustellen.
Ich war ein normaler
mechanischer Angestellter.
Eines Tages sagte Tahir,
man müsse Dokumente einscannen.
Er wolle keinen Papierkrieg mehr.
Man stellte in der Firma
Computer auf..
..und schloss
eine externe Harddisk an.
Ich habe das überwacht
und z.T. eingescannt.
Khan hat diese Dokumente..
..in seinem Büro oder der Wohnung
in Dubai aufbewahrt.
Er besass eine Residenz dort.
Es waren 10 bis 12 Pilotenkoffer
voll mit Plänen und Instruktionen.
Einige hatten zu tun
mit Zentrifugen,..
..andere mit Uranium-Metallkunde
und andere mit Nuklearwaffen.
Man könnte es
Khans Bibliothek nennen.
Sie enthält einige der wichtigsten
nuklearen Geheimnisse der Welt.
Hier haben wir jemanden,
der sehr eng mit Nordkorea,..
..dem Iran und v.a.
mit China zusammenarbeitete.
In der unteren Ecke der Dokumente
war ein Zeichnungskopf.
Dort stand die Firma, der
Auftraggeber oder der Hersteller,..
..also allgemeine Informationen.
Dieser Teil wurde immer von Tahir
mit einer Schere abgeschnitten.
Das waren hochgeheime Dokumente,
die nur wenige sehen durften.
Designs für kleine Atombomben, Pläne
für neuste Anreicherungstechniken.
Die Zahl war sehr hoch.
Es waren, glaube ich, mehr
als 100 sehr grosse Zeichnungen.
Und so richtete man
den Computer so ein,..
..dass er zuerst eine Kopie
auf die Harddisk machte..
..und dann intern abspeicherte.
Wer hat das gemacht?
Z.T. ich.
Zuerst war es ein Fehler, dass es
auf der Harddisk gespeichert wurde.
Dann sah man,
dass dort Kopien drauf sind.
Man begann, dort nachzulesen.
In Zukunft hat man alles, das ge-
scannt wurde, automatisch abgelegt.
Also  S i e  haben das gemacht?
Ja, ich habe es gemacht.
Irgendwann liest man
eingescannte Dokumente..
..und entdeckt dabei
merkwürdige Dinge.
Das sind z.B. Urenco-Dokumente,
die man einscannen musste.
Es hatte mit Anreicherung zu tun
oder etwas in diesem Sinn.
Ich habe den Zusammenhang
nicht verstanden.
Ich schaute im Internet nach
und verstand die Zusammenhänge.
Man recherchierte über Khan und
wusste, was ihm vorgeworfen wurde.
Irgendwie ist man blitzartig
in etwas drin,..
..in dem man gar nicht sein möchte.
Die Dokumente, die er kopierte,..
..sorgen heute
in der Schweiz für Aufsehen..
..und verursachten einen
parlamentarischen Sonderbericht.
Aber noch, sagt Urs Tinner,..
..habe er keinen Kontakt
mit Geheimdiensten gehabt.
Die Gelegenheit habe sich
erst später ergeben,..
..in Malaysia, in der Firma Scomi.
Nach dem Auffliegen des Netzwerks
darf die Presse hier kurz filmen.
Tahir und Khan
produzierten in dieser Firma..
..heimlich Teile
für das Nuklearprogramm.
Tinner sagt, er habe hier
in Eigeninitiative versucht,..
..den Geheimdienst
auf sich aufmerksam zu machen.
Man konstruiert ein Rohr
mit verschiedenen Fenstern.
Es ist eine durchlöcherte Sache,
aber das Grundrohr bleibt.
Damit geht man an Ausstellungen.
Wenn Geheimdienste
das aufdecken wollen,..
..gehen sie zur Firma und schauen,
was sie macht und ausstellt.
Wenn das bei jemandem etwas auslöst,
muss man ja ein Echo hören.
Irgendwann kam man zum Kontakt.
Können Sie das genauer sagen?
Darüber rede ich nicht,
weil ich es versprochen habe.
Die CIA rekrutierte Urs Tinner
Ende 1999 oder anfangs 2000.
Und er wurde
zu einem wichtigen Informanten..
..über die Aktivitäten
des A.-Q-Khan-Netzwerkes.
Jemanden mit diesem Zugang
in einer Organisation zu haben,..
..das ist unschlagbar.
Urs Tinner war der Traum
jedes Geheimdienstes.
Was passierte beim ersten Treffen?
Es wurde erklärt, worum es geht
und was man wem vorwirft..
..und ob man mitmachen will.
Die Ware, die ich hatte,
übergab ich beim ersten Treffen.
Spannungserzeugende Musik
Hatten Sie nicht Angst?
Sicher hat man Angst.
Man kann nie telefonieren, wenn man
will, weil es abgehört wird.
Da gibt es so viele Dinge.
Es ist ein schwieriges Leben.
Man hat irgendwie immer Angst.
Im Haus wird jede Tür
einzeln abgeschlossen,..
..bis zum Schlafzimmer,
in dem man sich befindet.
Es gibt wirklich Tage,
an denen man Angst hat.
Es gab Situationen in Malaysia,
in denen ich nicht nach Hause ging.
Ich lebte 3 bis 4 Tage
im Hotelzimmer.
Man hatte einfach Angst,
es könnte etwas sein.
Man kann sich kaum vorstellen,
in seiner Haut zu stecken.
Jeden Tag dieser Druck, jeden Tag
die bange Frage, ob man auffliegt.
Und wer weiss, was passiert wäre,
wenn er aufgeflogen wäre,..
..bevor er die Informationen
dem Geheimdienst übergeben konnte?
Urs Tinner sagt,
aus Sicherheitsgründen habe er..
..seine Informationen
ins Rheintal geschickt.
Es sei Bruder Marco Tinner gewesen,..
..der im Jahr 2003 mit der CIA
einen Vertrag abschloss:
Man deckte das alles auf,
als man noch keinen Vertrag hatte.
Man arbeitete später miteinander..
..und bekam Spesen für Reisen
und verschiedene Sachen.
Ihr Anwalt hat ja bestätigt,..
..dass Ihre Familie
eine Million bekommen hat.
Haben Sie von diesem Geld
je etwas gesehen?
Ich habe sehr wenig davon gesehen.
Das Geld, das ich bekam,
gab ich weiter.
Ich hatte mit den Finanzen
nichts zu tun.
4.10.2003:
Im Mittelmeer steuert
die italienische Küstenwache..
..auf den deutschen Frachter
BBC China zu.
Zusammen mit Agenten des amerika-
nischen und britischen Geheimdiensts.
Das Aufbringen der BBC China im Jahr
2003 war das wichtigste Ereignis.
Ohne das hätten wir Gaddafi,
den libyschen Herrscher,..
..nicht überzeugen können,
sein Atomprogramm aufzugeben.
Hier sahen wir und die
Öffentlichkeit die Bestandteile..
..und das Ausmass des Projekts.
Und das half wahrscheinlich Libyen
zu gestehen.
Die Beschlagnahmung des Materials
auf dem Schiff BBC China..
..brachte den klaren Beweis..
..der Involvierung
des A.-Q-Khan-Netzwerkes.
Sie verkauften buchstäblich
von A bis Z alles,..
..um eine Atombombe zu bauen.
Auf der BBC China wissen
die Geheimagenten genau,..
..was sie suchen müssen:
Aus der riesigen Menge von Containern
wählen sie gezielt 5 Behälter aus.
Diese Information stammt von ihm,
sagt Urs Tinner.
Man machte die Lieferung
der BBC China ausfindig.
In der letzten grossen Lieferung
war am meisten drin.
Und man musste das Material
aus dem Verkehr ziehen.
Statt auf "Senden",
drückte man auf "Kopieren".
Man fluchte, zerknüllte das Papier
und schmiss es in den Papierkorb.
Somit war eine Kopie im Papierkorb
und die Sekretärin faxte es richtig.
Wenn dann mal
niemand anwesend war,..
..nahm ich die Kopie
und hatte die Informationen.
Ohne ihn und seine Informationen..
..hätten sie vermutlich das Schiff
nicht aufbringen können.
Noch am gleichen Tag befiehlt Tahir
Urs Tinner zu sich nach Dubai.
Er vermutet,
Tinner habe ihn und Khan verraten.
Man versuchte herauszufinden,
wer es war.
Tahir wurde energisch und laut.
Er wollte herausfinden,
wo der Fehler liegt.
Tinner erklärt ihm,
er könne es nicht gewesen sein.
Der Frachter sei erst..
..auf der 2. Reiseetappe
Dubai-Libyen gestoppt worden.
Wenn ich der Verräter
gewesen wäre,..
..hätte man das Schiff zwischen
Malaysia und Dubai rausgenommen.
Haben Sie das verlangt?
Es wurde verlangt,
dass es nicht dazwischen passiert.
Sonst wäre es klar gewesen,
wo der Fehler liegt.
Die Angst war da,
dass man auffliegen könnte.
Die US-Behörden präsentieren später
die Ausrüstungen,..
..die sie nach dem Auffliegen der
BBC China in Libyen beschlagnahmen:
..Uran-Zentrifugen und Kisten
mit pakistanischen Beschriftungen,..
..Direktlieferungen aus Pakistan.
Präsident George W. Bush
besichtigt persönlich den Fund.
Ich besichtigte gerade
diese gefährlichen Teile.
Heute sind die Welt und Libyen
sicherer,..
..weil diese Bestandteile
beschlagnahmt wurden.
Libyen hat das Atomwaffen-..
..und Langstreckenraketen-Programm
aufgegeben.
Ich glaube, dass die Zerschlagung
des wahrscheinlich..
..grössten privaten Exports für
nukleares Material und Know-how..
..die Welt sicherer machte.
Es wäre für mich
eine schreckliche Vorstellung,..
..wenn Khan noch 20 oder 30 Jahre
weitergemacht hätte.
A. Q. Khan wird in Pakistan auf Druck
der Amerikaner vorläufig festgenommen
Das Netzwerk ist gestoppt.
Bern, Bundeshaus:
Noch weiss die Öffentlichkeit
nichts von Tinners Rolle.
Doch die Schweizer Regierung
wird ins Vertrauen gezogen,..
..wie der ehemalige Justizminister
bestätigt:
Wir hatten nur erste Anzeichen
aus verschiedenen Staaten.
Sie sagten,
der Fall Tinner sei heikel.
Er habe eine grosse Bedeutung bei
der Nichtverbreitung von Atomwaffen.
Die Atomenergieagentur Wien:
Sie überwacht und kontrolliert
international Atomanlagen.
Sie wird sofort alarmiert.
Die Ermittler reisen nach Libyen,
um die Vorwürfe abzuklären.
Sie sehen, dass die Zentrifugen
pakistanischer Bauart sind.
Die libysche Regierung
gab das Programm zu.
Und so flogen El Baradei,..
..ich und andere
an Weihnachten 2003 nach Libyen.
Wir sahen zum ersten Mal
ihre Zentrifugen.
Und dann war es sofort klar:
gleiche Grösse, gleiche Bauart.
Die Ware auf dem Schiff BBC China..
..war für den libyschen
Militärherrscher Gaddafi bestimmt,..
..für sein geheimes Atomprogramm.
Jetzt ist plötzlich alles bekannt.
Gaddafi, unter Druck, entscheidet
sich, offen zu kooperieren.
Einer der libyschen Leiter des
Anreicherungsprogramms sagte uns,..
..A. Q. Khan habe ihm
am Ende eines Treffens..
..einen oder 2 Plastiksäcke
mit Dokumenten überreicht.
Khan habe ihm gesagt:
"Wenn Sie einmal etwas weiter sind
mit der Uran-Anreicherung,..
..können diese Dokumente
für Sie hilfreich sein."
Atombomben-Pläne, überreicht in einem
Plastiksack mit diesem Aufdruck.
Der Aufdruck führt zurück
nach Pakistan,..
..zum
Good-Looks-and-Fabrics-Geschäft.
Es ist ein Plastiksack
aus dieser Schneiderei,..
..dem bevorzugten Geschäft
von A. Q. Khan.
Und tatsächlich
finden wir hier sein Bild.
Diese Dokumente waren ganz anders.
Es ging nicht
um Zentrifugentechnologie,..
..sondern um den Bau
von Nuklearwaffen.
Ich wurde relativ schnell von
der Firma in Malaysia entlassen..
..und hatte 3 Tage Zeit,
das Land zu verlassen.
Tahir liess Dinge verschwinden.
Er gab mir DVDs,
die ich vernichten musste.
Ich habe das Zeug mitgenommen
und weitergegeben.
Urs Tinner
reist zurück in die Heimat.
Seine Arbeit als Spion ist zu Ende.
Jetzt beginnt eine neue Phase.
Er, sein Bruder Marco und Vater
Fred Tinner fahren nach Wien.
Sie treffen Olli Heinonen..
..von der Atomenergieagentur
im Hotel Intercontinental.
Fred Tinner sagte, sie wollten
über ihre Beteiligung sprechen.
Er sagte, er habe das Gefühl,..
..sie könnten und müssten uns
bei den Ermittlungen helfen.
Vater wusste von früher
offenbar noch Dinge.
Wir gingen zusammen, manchmal sprach
man einzeln, manchmal in der Gruppe.
Jeder trug das bei, was er konnte.
Man hatte jahrelang mit Tahir
und verschiedenen Sachen zu tun.
Man wusste,
wie die Zeichnungen aussahen.
Es gibt Details,
aus denen man schliessen kann,..
..was miteinander verstrickt ist.
An mehreren Sitzungen
wird das A.-Q.-Khan-Netzwerk..
..mit Tinners Hilfe durchleuchtet.
Es war nützlich,
weil wir so die Organisation..
..dieses Netzwerkes
verstehen konnten und erfuhren,..
..über was für Informationen
es verfügte.
Tinners informieren
die Atomenergieagentur auch..
..über den sensibelsten Teil
von Khans Aktivitäten:
..die hochgeheimen Atombomben-Pläne.
Als sie uns die Existenz..
..von Informationen
in elektronischer Form erklärten,..
..waren wir in der Lage, unsere
Ermittlungen anders zu gestalten.
Wir konnten dann einige von
diesen Dokumenten beschlagnahmen.
Wenige Monate später
nimmt der Fall eine neue Wende.
Die Schweizer Justiz
verhaftet zuerst Urs Tinner,..
..später auch seinen Bruder Marco
und Vater Tinner.
Hauptvorwurf: Export
von nuklearem Kriegsmaterial,..
..u.a. in den Behältern,..
..die auf der BBC China mit
Urs Tinners Hilfe entdeckt wurden.
Die Polizei beschlagnahmt
auch die elektronischen Bombenpläne.
Diese wollte Tinner der
Atomenergieagentur IAEA vorlegen.
Diese Dinge,
die noch bei mir zu Hause waren,..
..wären die Woche drauf
auch weg gewesen.
Ich hatte ca. am 16. den Termin.
Die Dokumente waren gekennzeichnet,
dass sie für die IAEA waren.
Urs Tinner sitzt jetzt
in Untersuchungshaft.
Er gilt in der Öffentlichkeit
als gefährlicher Nuklearschmuggler,..
..als Bösewicht,
als skrupelloser Bombenbauer.
In Bern merken die Behörden
zuerst nicht,..
..auf was für heiklen Papieren
sie sitzen.
Bis die Bundesanwaltschaft..
..Olli Heinonen von der
Atomenergieagentur zu Rate zieht.
Der damalige Justizminister Blocher
erinnert sich:
2006 gelangte die Bundesanwaltschaft
an mich.
Sie sagte, wir haben in diesem Fall
Tinner sehr heikle Unterlagen.
Das wurde von der Internationalen
Atomenergieagentur festgestellt.
Wir haben den Schweizer Behörden
auch gesagt,..
..dass es Material gäbe, das
mit Nuklearwaffen-Bau zu tun habe,..
..zusätzlich zum Zentrifugen-Mate-
rial, welches ziemlich heikel ist.
Für diese Dokumente
braucht man ein spezielles Wissen.
Es ist nicht einfach zu verstehen.
Deshalb offerierten wir der Schweiz
unsere Hilfe.
Auch das Weisse Haus
mischt sich jetzt ein.
Der Schweizer Justizminister Blocher
reist im Sommer 2007 nach Washington.
Die Verhaftung ihres Spions Urs
Tinner durch die Schweizer Behörden..
..stösst hier auf Unverständnis.
Dass ich dorthin ging und wen ich
alles sah, das veröffentlichte ich.
Ich habe auch Themen angegeben,
die wir besprochen haben.
Aber dieses Thema nicht.
Die USA wollen von der Schweiz
auch die beschlagnahmten Bombenpläne.
Vielleicht, weil dort auch amerika-
nische Geheimnisse enthalten sind:
Wir wollten die Unterlagen,
weil das für sie sicherer ist.
Ich musste sie davon überzeugen,..
..dass wir sie ihnen
nicht geben können.
Kurz nach Blochers Rückkehr fällt
der Bundesrat den ersten Entschluss.
Er verbietet,
die Tinners als Spione anzuklagen.
Im Falle von Spionage ist der
Bundesrat dazu gesetzlich ermächtigt:
Über die Gründe, warum man es
nicht tut, gibt man nie Auskunft.
Ich möchte auch hier
keine Auskunft geben.
Der Bundesrat hätte es
stossend empfunden,..
..wenn man die Ermächtigung
erteilt hätte,..
..um die Strafverfolgung
zu machen.
Nicht verbieten kann der Bundesrat
der Justiz,..
..gegen Tinners wegen Lieferung
von Nuklearmaterial zu ermitteln.
Der Bundesrat fällt wenig später
einen weiteren Beschluss:
Er beschliesst, die beschlagnahmten
Bombenpläne zu vernichten.
Die entsprechenden Ämter, das war
v.a. das Departement des Äusseren,..
..sagten uns klar, dass wir solche
Unterlagen nicht haben dürfen.
Auch das Bundesamt für Justiz
bestätigte das.
Und die Internationale Atomenergie-
agentur wies uns darauf hin.
Wir halfen ihnen, die heiklen
Dokumente zu identifizieren.
Es war ihre Entscheidung,
diese zu zerstören.
Unsere Leute waren dort.
Es war wichtig, einen sehr genauen
Katalog zu erstellen über das,..
..was zerstört wurde.
Denn falls dieser Fall
wieder aktuell wird,..
..ist es wichtig zu wissen,
was dort war.
Gruppierungen,
Terroristengruppen, Staaten,..
..die eigene Atombomben bauen
oder Lenkwaffen möchten,..
..das sind unglaublich
interessante Sachen.
Und was passiert mit solchen Sachen,
wenn man weiss, dass wir sie haben?
Das hat sich ja
langsam herumgesprochen.
Man hätte angefangen,
das Land zu erpressen:
"Gebt es heraus,
sonst passiert das und das!"
Das könnte
bis zu Entführungen führen.
Sie brauchten mehrere Wochen
für die Zerstörung.
Sie gingen systematisch vor.
Jedes Dokument wurde
identifiziert und benannt,..
..sowie das Zerstörungsdatum
festgehalten.
Die Papiere wurden
geschreddert und verbrannt.
Computer-Harddisks
wurden unlesbar gemacht..
..und schliesslich noch zerstampft.
Das ist ein grosses
Sicherheitsrisiko für ein Land.
Die internationale Atomenergieagentur
prüft die Tinner-Information weiter.
Sie fährt fort
mit der Analyse des Khan-Netzwerks.
Und sie stösst auf den Iran.
Es war klar für uns,
dass wir genauer hinschauen müssen.
Und es schien, dass es Verbindungen
Richtung Iran gab.
Die Leute, die Informationen
und Teile an den Iran weitergaben,..
..schienen die gleichen zu sein
wie diejenigen,..
..die Teile an Libyen lieferten.
Der iranische Dokumentarfilm
mit dem Titel "Wir können".
Bombastisch wird das angeblich
friedliche Atomprogramm erklärt.
Fakt ist, dass der Iran die Techno-
logie zuerst von A. Q. Khan erhielt.
Fakt ist auch: Der Iran erlebt
mehrere Rückschläge infolge Sabotage.
Im Film erklärt der Leiter des
Programms, was genau passiert ist.
Wir besorgten uns..
..solche Zentrifugenpumpen
in einem europäischen Land.
Als wir sie einsetzten,
explodierten die Zentrifugen.
Nach einer Diagnose
stellten wir fest,..
..dass die Pumpen manipuliert waren.
Sie wollten uns täuschen.
Wenn nicht Urs Tinner, wer sonst?
Es muss jemand gewesen sein,
der im Netzwerk war,..
..damit er die sabotierten Teile
einschleusen konnte.
Ich denke, Urs Tinner
ist der Verdächtige Nummer 1.
Als Urs Tinner im Schweizer Gefängnis
sitzt, besucht Olli Heinonen ihn.
Sie sprechen u.a. über Sabotage:
Wir brauchten immer noch ihre Hilfe.
Wir setzten unsere Ermittlungen
fort. Es gab neue Informationen.
Worum ging es?
Es ging um Endabänderungen.
Die Teile bestanden früher
aus Aluminium.
Diese Teile wurden
aus 2 Röhrchen gemacht.
Ein Röhrchen war aus Aluminium..
..und darin befand sich eines
aus Edelstahl.
Man weiss,
dass diese Sachen warm werden.
Der Ausdehnungskoeffizient
von Aluminium..
..ist grösser als von Edelstahl.
Wenn es warm wird
bei Betriebstemperatur,..
..dann fallen sie auseinander.
Diese Dinge sind funktionstüchtig,
bis sie das erste Mal laufen.
Das untere Röhrchen fällt raus.
Die Anlage läuft zwar noch,
aber es gibt keine Produkte mehr.
Diese Dinge schaute man
mit Heinonen an.
Wohin die sabotierten Teile gingen,
wisse er nicht, sagt Tinner.
Die Schweizer Justiz untersuchte..
..während den jahrelangen
Ermittlungen nicht,..
..ob Tinner an der Iran-Sabotage
beteiligt war.
Die Behörde sagt,
ein Gutachten habe ergeben,..
..dass Khans Ware für Libyen
nicht sabotiert worden sei.
A. Q. Khan wurde nie verurteilt.
Er darf zu Hause keine ausländischen
Journalisten mehr empfangen,..
..aber telefonische Interviews
gibt er:
Was sagen Sie zum Vorwurf,..
..er hätte mit dem US-Geheimdienst
zusammengearbeitet?
Selbst gegen den milden Hausarrest
von A. Q. Khan..
..protestieren islamische Parteien
in Pakistan mit Demonstrationen.
Er spricht Urdu.
A. Q. Khan ist unser Held.
Er hat Grossartiges
für Pakistan getan.
Soll die Welt zur Hölle gehen, wenn
sie sagt, er sei ein Schmuggler!
Der ehemalige Geheimdienstchef Gul..
..hat enge Kontakte
zu extremistischen Islamisten.
Und er kennt Osama Bin Laden.
Will Osama Bin Laden die Atombombe?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Wir haben nicht darüber gesprochen,
als ich ihn getroffen habe.
Aber es ist Krieg. Amerika greift
zu allen Mitteln. Es ist möglich.
Es gibt keinen Zweifel,
dass Osama Bin Laden..
..und seine Al-Kaida-Organisation
eine Atombombe möchten.
Die Amerikaner zerstören die Zi-
vilisation und Kultur Afghanistans.
Im Krieg ist alles erlaubt.
Pakistan:
Hier fehlt offenbar hoch ange-
reichertes bombenfähiges Uranium..
..in den Research-Laboratorien
von Dr. A. Q. Khan.
Als die pakistanische Regierung
nach Khans Absetzung..
..die erste richtige Betriebsprüfung
machte,..
..entdeckte sie, dass grosse Mengen
verschwunden waren.
Wohin sind sie verschwunden?
Hat man sie dem Iran gegeben?
Möglich. Nordkorea? Möglich.
Oder irgendwohin sonst.
Die Tatsache, dass es
bezüglich waffenfähiges Uranium..
..überhaupt ein Fragezeichen gibt,
ist schon beängstigend.
Es gibt reale Angst darüber,
wohin das Material verschwand..
..und ob es immer noch
auf dem Markt zum Verkaufen ist.
Pakistan ist meiner Meinung nach
das gefährlichste Land der Welt.
Alle Alpträume der Welt..
..kommen hier in einer einzigartig
explosiven Weise zusammen.
Wir haben das Problem der
Verbreitung von Nukleartechnologie.
Wir haben die ernste Gefahr eines
Krieges zwischen Indien und Pakistan
Im letzten Jahrzehnt
waren die beiden Länder..
..schon 2-mal fast im Kriegszustand.
Wir haben das Problem
des Terrorismus.
Die Heimat von Al Kaida
ist Pakistan.
Khan war nicht nur ein Schmuggler
von Technologien.
Er war auch ein Schmuggler
von Wissen.
Wenn Wissen einmal verteilt wurde,..
..dann verteilt es sich
immer schneller.
Immerhin: Gaddafi musste
sein Atomprogramm aufgeben.
Und Irans Programm
erlitt dank Sabotage Rückschläge.
Urs Tinner aber brachte seine CIA-
Mitarbeit in der Schweiz kein Glück.
Ich verbrachte
fast 5 Jahre in U-Haft.
Man sitzt in einer 3 mal 2 m
grossen Zelle..
..und kann
kein normales Gespräch führen.
Man sitzt allein in einem Raum
und hat fast nichts zu tun.
Ich war über 1 1/2 Jahre
in Isolation.
Ich hatte keinen Kontakt
zu Mitinsassen.
Ich sah ausser den Wärter,..
..der mir das Essen brachte,
und den Pfarrer niemanden.
Das macht in einem Menschen
sehr viel kaputt.
Für die Internationale
Atomenergieagentur..
..gibt es noch immer offene Fragen.
Wir wissen immer noch nicht,..
..wo überall solche Dokumente
gespeichert waren.
Deshalb müssen wir
unsere Ermittlungen fortsetzen.
Die Fabrik von Vater Tinner
ist inzwischen geschlossen,..
..die Räume sind zu vermieten.
Urs Tinner sagt, er fürchte
die Rache des aufgedeckten Netzwerks.
Es gibt Leute, die damit
viel Geld verloren haben.
Einige haben ein Projekt verloren.
Schlussendlich
sucht man einen Schuldigen.
Irgendwo wird immer
ein Schuldiger gesucht.
Ich riskiere wahrscheinlich
heute noch mein Leben.
Man weiss noch nicht,
was wie endet.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft und die CIA
lehnen jede Auskunft ab.
Eine Anklage gegen Urs,
Marco und Vater Friedrich Tinner..
..wegen Lieferung von nuklearem
Kriegsmaterial ist nicht in Sicht -..
..trotz jahrelanger Untersuchung.